[MUSIC]
Thank you everyone for being here,
and thank you Jill for
being here with us today.
>> I'm so honored to be your
final speaker, so thanks.
>> We've chosen very, very carefully.
>> [LAUGH].
>> You've devoted your entire
life to journalism, and
you often tell your journalist to
get the story behind the story.
So, most people know
your story as the first
female executive editor
of the New York Times.
But, we are hear today and very honored to
get to learn your story behind the story.
And, in particular,
I want to touch upon some of the early
influences that shaped who you are.
>> Sure.
>> Your tenure at the Times,
your management philosophy, and
your thoughts on this very,
very rapidly changing industry.
So, I'll take us back in time when you
were growing up in New York with your
family.
And you once said The New York Times
took the place of religion.
At the time said it,
it was the absolute truth.
Now, you might not have predicted
that you'll be running this very
publication years later.
>> Certainly not.
>> But, what
were the early influences that
got you interested in journalism?
>> I actually got into
a little bit of hot water for
saying that The Times substituted for
religion in my household, on social media.
There were a lot of people
denouncing my heathen comments.
But, it had the virtue in
my growing up of actually
being true because my
parents weren't religious,
but they had a very reverential
attitude towards The New York Times.
And if some big story was
published in The New York Times,
that was the truth to them.
And, I grew up inculcated with
that same kind of admiration and
belief in the accuracy and
integrity of the information that was in
that newspaper, which back then,
of course, was just the print newspaper.
To give you an idea, I grew up on
the upper west side of Manhattan,
how devoted Times readers my parents were.
We actually had two home
delivery subscriptions
because my father liked to
take his with him to work.
And my mother, who was the most
devoted puzzler I've ever known,
she did the puzzle in pen,
even on the hard days.
She didn't like anyone kind of
touching her New York Times.
Like, she wanted a pristine puzzle.
She don't like to tear the puzzle out.
So, we had two home
delivery subscriptions.
And I can remember, at a very young age,
when I was probably 12 getting real,
I got very interested in movies,
the old movies at that point.
And just becoming so
devoted to like the arts pages of
The Times were sort of my introduction.
If I wanted to know, culturally,
what was happening in New York,
I'd grab for the arts page of-
>> Well, you went from an avid
reader to launching your
career in this industry.
You started with the Legal Times, and
spent almost a decade at the Wall Street
Journal, as an investigative journalist.
>> Right.
So, most of us here probably don't
quite have an idea of what exactly is
the life of an investigative journalist.
Can you tell us a little
bit what that was like and
some of the early challenges
you had to overcome?
>> Well, but the life of an investigative
reporter is often the key if you
want to get hold of secret, confidential
documents to buttress your story.
Sometimes it's lonely work,
kind of green, old green eyeshade,
kind of work of just sifting through piles
of documents that you may have been given,
looking for the diamonds in the rough,
in those documents.
It can be trying to locate
people in remote places.
I mean, a vivid memory of mine from
back at the Wall Street Journal.
It's not one of my daughter's
favorite memories, but
I was doing some Investigative reporting
on overseas donations that had
come to the Democratic National Committee
during Bill Clinton's reelection in 1996.
And these donations were being
given through straw donors,
the money hadn't really been the
individuals who reported the donations.
But their addresses were listed and
many of these people lived
in communities surrounding
in suburban Maryland, suburban Virginia.
And when I began driving to
try to go to these addresses,
I could see immediately that it
was very unlikely that these were
people who could afford to
give $50,000 to the DNC.
And my daughter at that point was playing
on a rotating soccer team in that area.
So I'd go to her soccer game and
then make her get in the car and
spend a couple of hours with investigative
reporter mom like going up to
these houses and knocking on the door.
And I remember her saying to me,
like, mom you can't do that.
[LAUGH] You know, it's not polite.
But, it's a little bit of
that kind of work too.
It's like old fashioned gumshoe reporting.
That isn't the first reporting I did.
The first job I got out of Harvard,
I had been a stringer for
Time Magazine while I was at Harvard,
covering different stories and
notable professors and
other things on the Harvard campus.
For you business students, that my most
vivid memory of that early reporting was,
I was constantly calling up John Kenneth
Galbraith, and asking him over and
over again, is the West in decline,
Professor Galbraith?
It got to be kind of a joke between us.
Like, if it was Friday it was like,
hi, Professor Galbraith, it's Jill.
Is the west in decline this week?
It was part-time reporting for
Time magazine.
At that point, the Boston bureau
chief of Time was a woman
named Sandra Burton,
who had begun at Time as a secretary.
And she had literally,
through dint of being a great curious
reporter and journalist,
literally clawed her way out
of the secretarial pool into
the correspondents ranks.
And she had become the first first
female bureau chief at Time in Boston.
And she was my first boss, and
she was incredibly encouraging to me.
And it was meaningful to her that even
though I was a freshly minted Harvard
student, I got a permanent job in
their office right after graduation,
that I get some meaningful experience and
learn how to really report.
And, do some hard reporting too, and
She then went on to be based in Asia for
a time, in Hong Kong.
And when I became Washington Bureau Chief
of the Times in 2000,
I was the first woman to have that job.
She sent me a telegram,
it was long enough ago that telegrams
were still being sent and her telegram
to me said she could hear the glass
shattering all the way to Hong Kong.
She was my first boss, and the only female
boss I ever had for the rest of my career,
except for the period at the time
when Janet Robinson was CEO
of the Times and I was managing editor,
I had a lot of interaction with her.
>> I would love to talk to you
more about the gender dynamics and
working as a female in
the journalism industry.
But you mentioned your times at the Times
now, and when now you're in a position
where you have to decide on a daily
basis what's fit or unfit to publish.
On one hand, you have obligation to
the audience to tell them the truth,
and on the other hand I know there's been
instances where the government told you,
you'll have blood on your hand if
you publish this article relating to
national security.
You had to make a lot of tough calls.
How did you make these calls, and what's
the framework you've used to do that?
>> It's a great question, and
one interestingly enough that
we spent three hours in
Professor Phillip Taubman's class,
where I visited yesterday,
his journalism class discussing just that.
Because when I was managing
editor of the Times and
Phil was the Washington Bureau Chief,
we had to actually consult on a number
of those difficult decisions.
And it's not like there's
an editing manual that
teaches you how to come to a perfect
decision in those situations.
And all of them are somewhat different,
because when the government asks for
either an entire story
to be not published,
or what is more common is
the government will ask for
certain details in a story
to be withheld on national
security grounds because
they think disclosure
of certain classified details
may put lives in danger.
It's agonizing every time you
get one of those requests.
I think what an editor has to do is,
I don't wanna sort of
get all heavy on you and
start invoking the Founders, but
what you have to do first and
foremost is remind yourself that
the Founders did give the press
enshrined in the First Amendment,
and it's first for a reason,
these very special protections,
because they believed so
vehemently in the importance of our
role in holding power accountable and
making sure power in this country
didn't become abusive and
too centralized.
Because that's what the Founders were so
deathly afraid of and felt they had
witnessed happening in Britain.
So you have to kind of
take a deep breath and
remind yourself that we're here first and
foremost to inform the citizenry.
To keep the public informed.
And that to keep genuinely
important newsworthy information
away from the public goes against
our wiring as journalists,
but nor
do we want to harm national security.
And particularly after 9/11,
the number of requests to withhold
information from stories and
in a few cases, hold stories back
from publication, began increasing.
>> Can you give us an example
of how you weigh the tradeoffs?
>> Sure, I mean one that is
a pretty prominent case that in
fact has been written about
involved probably the most
sensitive story about
classified intelligence that
the Times published when I
was managing it in 2005.
It was the first story that disclosed
that the NSA was doing warrantless
eavesdropping, which was actually
illegal because at that point
the NSA had to go to the FISA court
in each of the cases it wanted to
do eavesdropping, and
they were bypassing the FISA court.
They were just downloading
telephone communications.
And in that case,
the Bush administration pretty immediately
after the two reporters,
Jim Risen and Eric Lishblam,
began reporting on it said you
cannot publish that story.
That program, that eavesdropping Is the
crown jewel in our anti-terrorism program.
It has Michael Hayden,
a very senior intelligence official,
made assurances that the NSA
eavesdropping had literally
helped unplug some terrorism
plots that were in the works.
And in the Oval Office,
the then executive editor of the Times and
the publisher of The Times were told
by President Bush if we publish
the story we would have
blood on our hands.
And we held it for more than a year, but
the legality of this kind
of eavesdropping became
ever clearer as the reporters
continued to amass information.
And it seemed,
everything is a balancing test.
It's that, is the information so
compelling and important for
Americans to know?
Does that outweigh the possible
risk to national security?
And in the case of that story
we felt that the public in
whose name the war on terror was
being waged, they needed to know.
We weren't sure the public
would be comfortable
with those kinds of programs, which of
course kind of lead us now into the area
that Edward Snowden has
made his disclosures about.
But these are difficult cases, and
I think in all of them and that
this would be true at the Washington Post
or any other quality news organization,
that when you get requests from
the government, you hear it out.
You don't just get a leak and
then slap it into the newspaper without
hearing out those arguments and
giving them careful consideration.
>> You have a really tough job.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
with that I want to talk to you about
your leadership philosophy because,
as we know, the Times is
an extremely complex organization.
You have many different stakeholders.
You have the publisher,
the journalists, the audience, and
the government sometimes,
as we talked about.
And unlike most other companies where
they would have a longer product cycle,
the Times put out a new
product every single day.
And it can't be buggy.
>> And now with the web-
>> It's constant.
>> It's constant, yeah.
So how do you manage such
a Complex organization, with so
many moving parts under so
many constant deadlines?
It's a difficult organization to manage.
There's no question.
It's also a thrilling
organization to manage because
they have the best journalists in
the world who are expert in so
many subjects,
doing the highest quality work.
So on any given day,
I'd be reviewing a piece of multimedia
on the restored Islamic wing
at the Metropolitan Museum.
And then doing a close reading
of a story involving corruption
of Chinese princelings and China,
a long investigative story.
It was an incredibly varied menu
of journalism that I dealt with.
And journalism I think over time,
it's almost,
I think, so unlikely that I would have
become executive editor because my
background was in investigative reporting.
And typically investigative
reporters are lone wolves.
You're used to sort of hunting and
going after stories by yourself.
And journalism now, especially in
a multimedia world, has become so
much more collaborative.
The lone wolf story is the exception now.
I mean,
now most big stories at the Times and
other places involve teams of journalists,
data experts,
graphics editors, obviously,
photographers, videographers.
It's a team sport, and for someone whose
background was investigative journalism,
I'm not sure I would have been
the natural manager of these large team.
>> But you did lead as a manager.
>> Yeah, sure.
I think that probably my best leadership
quality was just my passion for
going after ambitious stories
that were gonna have high impact.
And that I was talented at being
able to think up ideas for
my colleagues that would be those
kinds of high-impact stories.
But the creative side of
storymaking was my background,
and obviously,
as I rose up in the organization,
I had to learn on the fly
all of the things that you
are studying here at
Stanford Business School,
which is business models.
Journalism is under stress,
i turns out that's the least
well-kept secret in the world.
>> Well, we will get to that.
>> The whole time that I
was managing editor and
then executive editor,
it was the business model is under stress.
Also, it's a thrilling time because
we're making the big digital
transition from the print past
into the digital present.
And that presented its own challenges.
>> You clearly had to
learn these skills as
your role changed from being an individual
reporter to now running the newsroom.
>> Right, I wish maybe that the Times
had sent me here for a year.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Derek Bolton should take note of that.
So, talking more about your
management philosophy.
I want to talk about your
management style at the Times, and
I read in other media outlets as
well that you were described as, and
I quote, abrasive, too pushy,
polarizing, impossible.
Did these come as shock to
you when you first read them?
>> You know,
I was obviously not happy to read those.
I wouldn't say I was completely surprised.
I was aware that my
style is hard-charging,
I hope you can tell, fairly direct and
direct in the way I talk.
I guess that, through the eyes of
some people could be seen as brusque.
I was always very ambitious for
the Times to have the best story,
and whether that sometimes translated into
pushiness, that wouldn't surprise me.
If that's so,
I felt the bottom line is that for
many journalists that I had worked with,
I inspired their best work.
And that that was very important and
my major strength.
I think that so many of the words
that you have just read are so
personality-focused, and
I'm certainly aware and
have read quite a lot of
literature on the fact
that when women are in leadership roles,
often it is those stylistic personal
issues that just get outsize focus,
and are kind of picked over to death, but-
>> Well,
do you think, on that note,
women are scrutinized in an unfair way?
>> I think sometime they're scrutinized
in a way that is a double standard.
That qualities that are seen
in a negative light,
when applied to women leaders,
are sometimes seen as
successful traits in men.
>> As we-
>> I want to also just kind of pause
here to say,
I don't anyone to misunderstand and
think I'm trying to say that I
was fired because I'm a woman.
I totally don't think that.
I think that some of the perceptions of
me were colored by some of these issues.
But I think that there were many issues
that came into play in
terms of the denouement,
and me getting fired, so,
just wanted to say that plainly.
>> What, if anything, do you think
you could have done differently?
>> I think that,
I've thought lots about that and
things that if I could do over,
I would do over.
I definitely would have spent
more time listening and
less time talking myself.
I think because of the period of time
I matured in my career that I had so
often been in the situation in
a meeting where I was the only woman,
where I felt I wasn't heard or
listened to that I think
perhaps by the time I got
into the big leadership jobs
at the Times I was overcompensating
by making sure I was
heard in a way that I think
probably didn't help me.
So listening more.
I think that because this was a period
of economic stress in the newsroom,
and I was so
determined to fight to preserve
every job of every
journalist in that newsroom
that I probably was not
the easiest person for
some of my business side colleagues
to deal with all the time.
I was very protective of the newsroom of
the New York Times and it's prerogative.
There had, for
my whole career, been a very
clear Chinese wall, it was always called
then, between the news and the business.
And I had sort of been trained to be
very protective of the newsroom and
to somewhat keep the business
side at bay on certain matters.
And I think that in a digital world, and
now I see the Times has
more jobs that are joint
reports to the business side and
the news side.
>From my period of time I was
very anxious about that and
probably pretty resistant to
it because I thought that
the journalism was best served
by being at arms distance from.
The advertising and
circulation sides of the paper.
And I think maybe looking back on it,
I was too protective.
>> And as we all here today walk out of
the auditorium to strive to change lives,
organization in the world, what are the
things that we can do as both men and
women to change the situation
at our workplace?
>> Well, I think you have to be clear and
focused in what you want to change,
first and foremost.
I don't think it's effective always
to have ten things that you wanna
change in your workplace.
But if there's one transcendent issue that
you really think needs to be transformed
and if it was that it would make where
you're working so much healthier.
I think being direct and not necessarily
being overly political, or
stepping on people's toes and
bringing that issue to the attention
of the people who run the company.
I think you should be
pretty forthright and
kind of kick ass about
trying to make change.
I really do.
>> You've definitely made a lot
of change in your life and
at the organization that you've been at.
And even after you got
fired from the Times,
Dean Saloner mentioned that you
were giving a commencement speech.
>> Yeah,
it wasn't two months after though.
>> It was almost like-
>> It was just a few days after.
It like the Sunday, I was fired on
a Wednesday, I think it was the following
Sunday I had agreed to be
the commencement speaker at Wake Forest.
And they were worried that
I was gonna withdraw, but
I had said yes and I was gonna go.
>> And I love this quote you said,
which is I'm talking to
anyone who has been dumped, have not
gotten the job you really wanted, or
have received those
horrible rejection letters.
You know the disappointment of losing.
When that happens,
show what you are made of.
So what are you made of, Jill?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, I think I'm made up of,
I am a resilient person, I think.
And I think anyone, who, when a lot of
you, I hate to tell you even you wonderful
Stanford business grads,
some of you are gonna get fired in
the course of your-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Career.
And work on that resilience thing.
It really helps.
I think I'm, I love to read,
I get a tremendous,
I just think the Times is still the best,
it's the most enjoyable
thing to sit down and read.
And I'm made up of someone
who just has tremendous
appreciation for
a beautifully crafted story.
I'm a very involved family person.
I have two children.
I met my husband my
sophomore year at Harvard.
We've been together since we're 20.
I'm a big dog person.
[LAUGH]
>> In fact you wrote
a book about your dog.
>> I did,
I wrote a whole book about my dog.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Silly though that may seem.
But I think that what I'm made of,
it goes back to my parents.
And my mother was very influential
in making me love reading so much.
But I had a father who really thought
he had two daughters that if we
set our mind to something,
we could do it if we worked hard enough.
And he even, when Daylight Savings Time
would come on the East Coast,
he would take a bat and a ball,
I was never a very good athlete,
out to Central Park and he'd have me hit.
And I'd be like I can't do it and
he'd be sure you can Jilly, sure you can.
He was very encouraging.
And the morning that it became public
that I'd been fired my
sister called me up.
And she said to me, you know what?
My father passed away in 1992.
But she said, our dad would be
as proud of you today as he was
when you became
Executive Editor of the Times.
And that was very meaningful to me.
And it made me all the more
wanna go to Wake Forest and
give that speech.
And that morning I had an appointment.
I'm also a gym rat.
That's what I'm made of, and that's right.
>> I saw that on Instagram.
>> So that's what I was gonna say.
The next thing I did, I had
an appointment to do personal training.
So I went to see my trainer, and when I
got there, he had these big red boxing
gloves and he handed them to me and
he said you need those today.
And he had on his big red boxing gloves,
and for the next hour,
I just like whacked at his
big red boxing gloves.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And it was incredibly therapeutic.
I hadn't brought my phone, but
I said to Gene my trainer I said,
do you have a phone?
Cuz I want to send my kids a picture.
I was worried that my kids would think
I was crying in bed or something.
So I wanted to show them mom
in the cool red boxing gloves.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so
he sent me a picture from his phone,
I sent it to them.
Then I went home, and
about 11:00 in the morning,
my daughter who is a surgeon in Boston,
I didn't know, she put it on Instagram.
>> She did.
>> She called me up and she said Mommy,
that picture's going viral.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And it was the wood,
which is the big top picture on
the next day's New York Post.
I must say it wasn't the most
flattering picture of me in like a.
Shirt but I guess that's me, too.
The fighting person.
>> Absolutely, and we also sent
that picture around to the GSVS.
>> Oh no!
[LAUGH] That picture in the Quad is so
much more attractive than that.
>> Before we open up the questions for Q&A
for the audience I wanna take some time
to get your thoughts on the future
of the journalism industry.
In five to ten years how do you
see people consuming media?
>> In every way possible.
I just was reading a story today that the
editor of USA Today was predicting in five
or six years that they wouldn't
be a print paper anymore.
But I certainly think the Times is
going to be around in print for
quite a while longer.
There's just a pretty robust,
I think something like
800,000 home delivery
print subscribers to
the Times here in California.
Evidently, that costs you who
like to get it in the blue bag,
more than $900 a year, I think.
So but, there's a healthy
number of people still who love
the serendipity of reading in print.
But news, like I'm actually,
I'm writing a book about all
the changes in the news industry.
And you know Snapchat
just hired away CNN's,
one of their top political reporters.
Snapchat is going to be
covering the campaign.
Facebook is obviously one of
the largest distributors of news.
So many people, their exposure to news
stories is coming in their Facebook feeds.
And increasingly,
I think the media business and
the tech business are kind
of merging in an odd way.
I don't know that the tech companies
are entirely comfortable stepping up and
taking some of the responsibilities
like we were talking about,
like having to think, do you hold
the story or publish the story.
They're relying on places like
the New York Times or Buzzfeed to make
those decisions for them, but
I don't know that that will last forever.
>> There's a recent deal with-
>> Everything Vine is a way,
these very short videos is
a major way news is spreading.
I think that broadly, rather than just
rattle off like a zillion changes,
I think the most interesting change
that's happening is that in my lifetime,
the power to decide what people
read resided in the editors'
offices of the major newspapers and
broadcast networks.
>> It resided in your hands.
In the beginning of me having those jobs,
it was in my hands.
I picked,
in consultation with other editors.
But the six stories that would be on
the front page of the New York Times.
And that those would automatically
be the most important stories
that the world would be reading.
But now we have gone to
a social model where more
readers are actually looking
at news that is picked
by their friends,
by people that they know,
not by Jill Abramson,
the editor of a newspaper.
And fewer readers are actually going to
a single destination to get their news.
They're reading links from all over the
place, so these are huge, huge changes.
And the thing that
interests me most of all,
because I think we can agree
we're living in an age
that I might call the age
of too much information.
There's so much news.
But I haven't seen a lot of great data
on whether that has made society,
and particularly younger people I
care about, now that I'm teaching,
whether it's actually made them more
deeply informed than they were before.
I'm very interested in
exploring that question.
>> We'll see that with time.
And with that,
I want to open up the floor for questions.
There are two mics on.
Nino has one over here,
Caroline has one over there.
Please raise your hand and
make sure they see you.
We're also taking questions from Twitter,
#gsbvftt.
Let's start with a Twitter question.
>> Hi, I have two tweets actually.
The first is in response to your
desire to spend a year at Stanford.
The MSX program tweeted that
you're welcome to come anytime.
So the second is-
>> But I'm not on top anymore,
what will I do with all of
those management skills?
[LAUGH]
>> They've made the offer.
The second thing is a question
from the crowd about
you talked about the future of media.
And there's a question about
whether there's a place for
smaller regional, more localized
coverage either in print or digital.
And whether you're seeing any business
models out there that are in that
space and that are working.
>> Yeah, the question about local news
is one that really has troubled me.
Because as regional and local newspapers,
which have been dependent on
classified advertising as their business
model, they have been just hammered.
And there are literally state legislatures
and city councils going uncovered now.
And that is just the press not
living up to the role that
the founders had, for
us to keep power accountable.
But I do see rays of hope.
And as I've been distressed at
the atrophying of local and
regional publications,
there are some great
digital news rooms that have
arisen focused on local news.
I was very supportive when
I worked at the Times,
we partnered with the Texas Tribune,
which was started six or
seven years ago by a guy named Evan Smith,
who was editor of
the Texas Monthly Magazine and
it covers Texas politics.
And they have I think a newsroom of 50
reporters focused on that, it's fantastic.
There's a digital publication called
MinnPost, in Minneapolis, that's fabulous.
The Texas Tribune's business model,
it's a nonprofit.
So Evan Smith has to go out and
raise money constantly, but
it's a successful model, and they do
The highest quality kind of journalism.
I just wish that could be
replicated in more localities.
>> They have a question over there.
>> Is it on?
Yeah.
So kinda along of the same lines
I was interested to hear that.
So if your book is about
shorter hits of news yet
your background is in
investigative journalism.
And I know you were looking at-
>> Why do you think it's about shorter
hits of news?
>> Sort of this is what you said around
six seconds from Vine or SnapChat.
>> Oh well that.
Yeah.
>> Right.
And then that's sort of being
an increasing way that we consume, but
I know that you were sort of working on
a venture around investigative journalism
>> Of long form, right.
>> And one big story.
So I wonder how you
sort of square the two,
especially sort of thinking about the
younger generation and how that fits in.
>> Right.
I think if you have a whale of a story
that's long, it finds a big audience.
I mean at the Times we found some
of the most challenging, long,
investigative stories zoomed to
most shared and most emailed.
So I don't believe everything
has to be short and
catered to the short attention span or
the size of a smart phone screen.
And I think just in the past year we've
seen a lot of great examples whether it's
the Time's recent investigation
of nail salons which went viral.
That was a long two-part series
where the popularity of Serial.
I mean Serial was 12
one-hour installments.
It was a true crime type of story.
But, that debuted on
This American Life and
by the second episode their audience had
ballooned to over a million listeners.
It very much brought about
a renaissance in podcasting,
which I think is very thrilling.
But, that long story, even though
they chopped it up into chapters.
I think there's like a human desire for
the long,
engrossing, fabulously reported,
elegantly told story.
And it takes us back to
the time of Charles Dickens,
when kind of like Serial, Dickens'
novels were shipped out in chapters.
And there would be Londoners standing on
the docks waiting for the latest chapters
of The Old Curiosity Shop to be delivered
because they were on pins and needles.
Is little Nell gonna be okay?
And that's fiction, but I felt a real-life
example of that was a story that I
championed at the Times where for
an entire week we did a close-in series
on a homeless girl named Dasani,
who lived in Fort Green, Brooklyn,
and against all the odds,
was battling to be a great twelve-year-old
who was learning a lot in school.
And it was readers were on
the edge of their seats
because of the way those stories
were edited and reported.
They were like page turners and
I just think that
there's a demand for that journalism now,
even along with the short stuff.
You may be surprised to here,
but BuzzFeed has a very
large investigative reporting unit,
which does long series,
some very good pieces and they have
15 full-time investigative reporters.
That's almost as big an investigative
reporting unit as the New York Times has,
so I'm very, very bullish on long form and
I think what I would leave
all of you with is I think
the ability to write a gripping,
clear narrative that that talent,
because you need it in business too,
you need it in every field,
it's never been a more
marketable skill than it is now.
I think narrative hath
incredible power and
that it's a skill that can be monetized.
>> One more question?
>> Hi Jill.
>> Hi.
>> Janie Lorber, New York Times,
Washington Bureau, 2008 through 2011.
>> Wow, yeah.
>> [LAUGH] I'm really concerned
about the monetization because I
went into journalism to be
an investigative reporter and
came here because I was worried
those jobs wouldn't exist.
How can you elaborate on how BuzzFeed is
supporting such a large
investigative unit?
Can you elaborate on whether we will
have public service journalism,
investigative journalism in ten years?
And how will we fund it?
>> I said I'm bullish on it and
I really mean it, Janie,
because I think obviously
investigative reporting
isn't where BuzzFeed is
making most of its money.
I mean it makes, I believe, most of
its money on branded advertising, and
of course, on the humorous listicles
that run every day that people
love to look at and share.
But I think that many of
these new places, almost as a prestige
thing, or to be taken seriously, or
let's give them the credit that actually
do want to help perform a public good and
inform the public, that as they mature and
become real institutions, they want
to be doing quality journalism, too.
And it isn't that different from
like back in the 1920s when
the comics help support
the coverage of World War II.
But it's gonna take some years more for
us to know whether there is a stable
business model for journalism.
And I guess where I've come out is,
you know.
Marty Barron of the Washington Post was
out here recently in California and
gave a fabulous speech and
said, the important thing is to
stop mourning what we have lost.
And I really believe that's important.
But he and an academic named Clay Shirky,
who I'm very smart,
kind of ascribed to it there isn't
going to be one business model answer.
It's not like there's
some great mega solution
sitting out there for
just someone really smart to discover.
You have to try a lot of different things.
So, I think for instance in New York some
people have said it doesn't make sense for
the New York Times which is trying
to have a digital subscription
model to suddenly be putting
its content on Facebook.
But by being on Facebook
they are increasing
the distribution of their story,
they're getting a bigger audience,
and maybe they will get some
subscriptions that way.
But I think you kind of have to do it all.
And that somehow being an optimist,
that's gonna bring quality
journalism to safe passage.
I really believe that because
it's a societal necessity.
>> One more question from Twitter?
>> Sure, yeah.
So you've been in an industry where you've
had to set your personal biases aside for
a long time.
And not the-
>> So, what are they?
[LAUGH]
>> Well, you knew it was coming.
No, the question is now that
you're no longer part of
a journalism organization and can speak
out on issues that you care about,
whether it's ones more personal to you or
ones you see going on in society, are you
gonna start doing that in your future?
Are you planning on doing that, or?
No I actually, the book I'm
working on is a reported book.
It will be reported narrative and
I want to go out a reporter.
I mean one of the really, if you can say
there was like a nice side to being fired.
It was like almost immediately
I went to reporting and
writing some pieces myself and
kind of rediscovering Jill Abramson
the individual journalist, the lone wolf,
I guess, which I always was.
And I want to hue to the journalism
standards that I always have.
So you're not going to see me giving big
donations to the Clinton Foundation.
[LAUGH]
>> Thank you so much, Jill.
I'm gonna have the honor to ask
you the last question of the day,
which is a View From The Top
tradition now.
What matters most to you and why?
>> What matters most to me now is
having an opportunity to give back and
to help younger people discover
a love of story telling and
being able to write and report stories.
So my teaching that I've
begun is very important.
I'm very Interested because I do
think we live in an age of narrative.
I'd love to work with
like a girls club and
teach even younger girls to write.
My family is vitally important to me,
I'm gonna become a first-time
grandma pretty soon.
>> Congratulations.
I can't wait to start a new generation,
with the love or reading and writing.
So that's what matters to me.
>> You can take your granddaughter to
go and hunt down the different houses.
>> Yeah, right.
[LAUGH]
>> Well, with that, thank you so much,
Jill Abramson.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]